what is going on everybody welcome to
the fifth Python debugging video this
video we're going to be talking about
attribute error and what causes
attribute error so in this case when
you're going to see this is this will be
the example every time so you can relate
let's say we want to do some sent decks
evaluation on I don't know some text so
we're going to import sent decks now the
next thing that we want to do is have a
variable so we'll have x equals and the
variables going to be some text that we
want to measure sentiment on so the text
will be a loser now now the way that
we'll let's say we wanted to calculate
that the sentiment of that so we'll your
send X dot calculate X but the problem
is there's no such thing is dot
calculate in sent X so we run this and
there is nothing in the sent X that has
that is calculate so sometimes you might
see this uh for example when you either
you try to do some sort of module that
doesn't exist but most often what it's
going to be is maybe the module has like
let's say let's say the module in sent X
was actually capital C calculate and
then you're writing out under case C
well when you did that it's going to
give you even if there really is a
module called calculate with a capital C
it's going to throw that air because you
type the lowercase e so that's just an
example of how you might come across
that issue and while we're on it since
it's a very easy transition to make
we'll do the import error so we have
setbacks but what if we try to import
some tags the double I actually Triple X
the kinky version of syntax let me try
to do that and then say x equals 5
and run that you're going to get an
import error it's going to say no module
name send X now why might you see this
besides a typo well it could be that you
actually haven't installed that module
so if you have an error in your
installation you'll throw that if you
have 64-bit Python and you install a
32-bit module you'll get import error
same with vice-versa if you were able to
even install it so there's that but I've
had it whenever whenever I first started
using 32-bit Python and then came across
the memory limits of 32-bit went to
64-bit and then I kept getting this no
module and I'm like what the hell I have
that module and that was why so anyway
that is import air and also attribute
error as always thanks for your support
your subscriptions and thanks for
watching but